نشهد بعض
الحركة الهجومية المضادة الأوكرانية المثيرة للاهتمام حقًا ،
هل يمكنك أن تأخذنا من خلال هذا نعم ، أنا
متحمس جدًا للحديث عن
الهجوم المضاد ، لقد كنت أرغب في
قول هذه الكلمة لفترة طويلة هناك
بعض الأنشطة الهامة مستمرة  في الوقت
الحالي ، رأينا للتو السفينة التي كانت
تنفجر هنا في ميناء البردات ،
ونحن نعلم أن هناك
هجومًا مضادًا مستمرًا في الوقت الحالي في curson ،
ونعلم أيضًا أنه في خاركيف هناك
دفعة قوية هناك لاستعادة
المجال الروسي الذي كان محتفظًا به سابقًا
الكثير من النشاط في
كييف واسمحوا لي أن أتحدث عن ذلك أولاً وقبل كل شيء
نعلم أن هذه المدينة هنا قد
تمت استعادتها وهذا أمر مهم للغاية ،
فهناك بلدة هنا بالقرب من
مطار أنطونوف التي تم حصارها
وهي تبعد حوالي ستة أميال عن أنطونوف إذا
يمكن للأورانيين أن يعيدوا حصار أه
مطار أنطونوف الذي سيكون
مهمًا للغاية بالنسبة لهم
لأسباب عديدة أه واه
من الواضح أنهم سيكونون قادرين على
منع الروس من الولايات المتحدة  كموقع إطلاق
أرض للميناء
هنا أيضًا ، يعد هذا أمرًا
مهمًا للغاية لقد دفعهم إلى
التراجع ، حيث يستخدمون التضاريس الرئيسية
لمحاربة الروس لإخراجهم من استخدام
المستنقعات والأنهار الموجودة هناك
ما يعنيه كل هذا في  kiev مهم جدًا ،
الآن لديهم حلقة 35 ميلًا
حول كييف محمية
وهذا يعني أنهم خارج نطاق المدفعية
وهذا شيء مهم للغاية
، لذلك من الجيد أن نتمكن من البدء في
الحديث عن المنتجات المزيفة لشيء
نحتاجه  لنفعل ذلك لأننا إذا أردنا
التفاوض مع فلاديمير بوتين ، فنحن بحاجة
إلى القيام بذلك من موقع قوة ،
فلدينا مقطع فيديو جديد تمامًا في CNN ، وهذا
يظهر سفينة روسية يقول الأوكرانيون إنها
مشتعلة
في مدينة بورغيس الساحلية الآن هذا هو
مدينة كانت تحت سيطرة
القوات الروسية ، هذا حريق في
حوض بناء السفن ، يقول الأوكرانيون على
متن سفينة إنزال روسية إن سفينة كانت في
الميناء لبعض الوقت ، وهي سفينة يمكنها
توصيل جميع
أنواع الإمدادات إلى غرون  هناك حريق هائل
يمكنك رؤيته هناك أيضًا بعض الانفجارات الثانوية ،
هناك خزان نفط كبير قريب
، قيل لنا أيضًا أن
بعض مستودعات الذخيرة ربما تنفجر
أيضًا مرة أخرى يقول الأوكرانيون أن هذا كان
إجراءً أوكرانيًا ضد هذه السفينة الروسية
في الميناء.
يبدو أنك تسمع عدد المرات التي
تخرج فيها من شقتك للحصول على
الإمدادات ،
فأنا لا أخرج كثيرًا لأنني
أعاني من نوبات ذعر شديدة
لذا يمكنني الخروج من دون شخص ما ، فأنا
خائف حقًا من الضوضاء العالية وصدرت ضوضاء عالية
في الخارج الآن ،
إنه يخيفني بعيدًا ، لذا
فأنا حقًا أنا أرتجف فقط أفكر في
الأمر الآن تبدو مدينتي
قليلاً مثل آه خلال وقت
كارثة الزومبي ، لا يوجد الكثير من
الناس يتجولون
خائف من الخروج لكني أرى الناس
ما زالوا يغادرون ، ولا يزالون
يذهبون إلى المتجر إلى محلات البقالة
لشراء بعض الطعام ولكن
لدينا نقص في المنتجات لنكون صادقين
لأن
الروس لا يسمحون للمساعدات الإنسانية
بالوصول إلى المدينة
[موسيقى]